el líder de la junta militar que se tomó
el gobierno en mianmar hizo su primer
pronunciamiento público desde el golpe
de estado que comandó hace una semana
dijo que la comisión electoral debe ser
reformada que habrá elecciones y
entregarán el poder al ganador llegaré
allí cuando hayamos completado el año de
la ley de emergencia procederemos bajo
la constitución de 2008 para realizar
una elección multipartidista y
entregaremos el poder a aquel que gane
esa elección de acuerdo a las reglas de
nuestra democracia y declaración llegó
al cierre del tercer día de protestas
contra la junta militar en mianmar este
lunes además de los estudiantes y grupos
de derechos humanos en las calles de
rangún la ciudad más grande del país
protestaron monjes budistas los
militares amenazaron con usar munición
letal si los manifestantes cruzaban las
líneas prohibidas
las manifestaciones llegan tras una
semana que parece una vuelta al pasado
el lunes primero de febrero los
militares declararon el estado de
emergencia por un año y se tomaron el
poder
dos días después trabajadores de 70
hospitales en el país detuvieron sus
actividades en señal de protesta y en
medio de una campaña de desobediencia
civil
[Música]
ese mismo 3 de febrero los militares
presentaron cargos en contra de la líder
aung san suu kyi y el presidente weening
también bloquearon facebook y whatsapp
el viernes mientras la junta detenía
wind game mano derecha de sus y los
profesores y algunos funcionarios del
estado se unían a los movimientos de
desobediencia civil
al día siguiente miles de personas se
tomaron las calles la junta bloqueó
twitter e instagram y ordenó apagar
todas las redes de internet se
instalaron el servicio el domingo pero
las redes sociales siguieron bloqueadas
este lunes el general a la cabeza de
mianmar no hizo mención alguna a la
líder birmana a un sandwich y mientras
occidente sigue pidiendo su liberación